.
Deuxième: ein Cordon bleu,
einmal Ravioli,
zweimal Wurzel vegan,
drei Züri gross, eine Tagessuppe.
Gabi, Ravioli und Züri gross.
How long?
8 Min.
- Wie viel?
- Ah.
Die Schweizer Gastroszene
ist zwar nicht systemrelevant,
aber relevant ist sie,
das hat die Pandemie gezeigt.
Neu zum Schicken: ein SpongeBob.
Wir alle haben realisiert: Wir lassen
uns gern im Restaurant verwöhnen -
darauf zu verzichten, fällt schwer.
Drei Nüssli. How long?
Die Gastronomie
ist eine harte Branche.
Die Arbeitszeiten lang
und unregelmässig,
und die Löhne sind bescheiden.
In der Gastronomie kann man
nicht mehr viel Geld verdienen.
Man arbeitet per se dann,
wenn alle anderen frei haben.
Service, bitte.
- Willst du das?
Zweimal Pommes, bitte.
Ja.
- Komm, Herzchen, komm.
Alle warten auf dich.
Es ist eigentlich bekannt, dass
es im Gastgewerbe schwierig ist,
dauerhaft schwarze Zahlen
zu schreiben
bzw. überhaupt
schwarze Zahlen zu schreiben.
Siehst du irgendwo
etwas Veganesisches?
An einem Tag wie heute
muss man einfach bereit sein.
Die Wagen und die Schubladen
müssen voll sein,
und man muss
jeden Handgriff optimieren.
Vom klassischen Landgasthof
zum Szenen-Pop-up,
von der Sterneküche
zur Betriebskantine,
allen ist etwas gemein:
Erfolgreich zu wirtschaften,
ist schwierig.
Hast du unten noch eine Rösti drin
oder steckst du in der Scheisse?
Nein.
- Dann steckst du in der Scheisse.
Neu zum Schicken:
zwei Lebern gross, zwei Cordon bleu,
ein Züri gross.
Viele Beizer
wirten am Existenzminimum
und die Coronapandemie führte
zu etlichen Betriebsschliessungen.
Laut einer Statistik sind 63 % der
Betriebe in der Schweiz defizitär.
Ich glaube, das stimmt nicht.
Die Kosten für Miete,
Personal und Lebensmittel sind hoch,
die Gäste anspruchsvoll.
Jedes Jahr
schliesst eines von vier Restaurants.
Wenn man diesen Betrieb hier
betrachtet und sich überlegt,
was alles nötig ist,
damit der Laden läuft ...
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Mein Name ist Christian Rösch.
Hier in der Wirtschaft Ziegelhütte
am Stadtrand von Zürich
habe ich im Sommer 2021
meine Lehre als Koch abgeschlossen.
Als begeisterter Hobbykoch
wollte ich die Welt
hinter der Gaststube kennenlernen
und habe nach 30 Jahren
als Filmemacher
nochmals etwas ganz Neues gewagt.
Als ältester Kochlehrling der Schweiz
zwei Jahre lang
die Schulbank gedrückt,
notabene zusammen
mit 18-jährigen Mitlehrlingen,
habe das Handwerk von der Pike auf
neu gelernt, habe Gemüse gerüstet,
Fleisch sautiert, Pommes frittiert,
bin langsam vom Gardemanger
in der kalten Küche
zum Saucier Fleisch und Fisch
aufgestiegen.
Diese Ausbildung hat mir Einblick
in eine Branche gegeben,
die jeder zu kennen glaubt.
Aber wie steht es
um diesen Wirtschaftszweig?
Warum ist es so schwer,
erfolgreich zu sein?
Und wer sind diese Menschen,
die von sich selbst sagen:
"Für diese Branche
musst du geboren sein."
Michel Grünlinger war zwei Jahre lang
mein Chef und Ausbildner.
Er ist wie immer der Erste
am Morgen in der Küche.
Mein Arbeitstag
beginnt in der Regel immer um 8 Uhr.
Dann gehe ich die Kühlhäuser durch
und kontrolliere,
was da ist, was es zu tun gibt
und was an dem Tag
noch produziert werden muss.
Und ich schaue, was an den
verschiedenen Stationen zu tun ist.
Ich verschaffe mir eine Übersicht.
Dann prüfe ich,
ob es Anlässe gibt.
Heute steht als Erstes unsere
neue Speisekarte auf dem Programm.
Wir wechseln vom Ochsen
vom Hof gegenüber
zu einer frühlingshaften
Speisekarte.
Wir müssen noch
die Mittagsmenüs vorbereiten.
Ich habe noch keine Ahnung, welche.
Und dann ...
Ich nehme die Knochen raus
und zupfe dann das Fleisch weg.
Michel bereitet
das sog. Mise en Place vor.
So nennt man in der Profiküche
die Vorbereitungen.
Dazu gehört, die Lebensmittel
womöglich vorzukochen,
aber auch Geräte und Kochgeschirr
bereitzustellen.
* Brutzeln und Zischen *
Heute ist der erste richtig
sonnige Sonntag dieses Jahres.
Es wird also etwas los sein.
Es gibt Leber,
Zürcher Geschnetzeltes
und italienische,
mediterrane Gerichte.
Wohlfühl-Küche.
Dinge, die ...
... unter dem Strich Spass machen.
Ich kochte schon immer extrem gern.
Das war immer mein Herzblut.
Ich wusste schon als Sechsjähriger,
dass ich Koch werden will.
Michel Grünlinger
und sein Souschef Gabriel Quiroga
besprechen den heutigen Tag.
(Frau) Morgen.
- Oh, es ist noch früh, was?
(Frau) Guten Morgen.
- Morgen.
Ähm ...
Gruppen haben wir heute keine, was?
- Doch.
Ja, die 14 Personen abends
mit dem Auswahlmenü.
Du hast genügend Leute, nicht wahr?
- Mhm.
Ich werde mich auf die Lieferscheine
vom Mai konzentrieren.
Die Rechnungen
sollten diese Woche noch kommen.
Dann kann ich den Mai abschliessen.
Also, auf in den Kampf. Wenn
etwas ist, meldest du dich.- Ja.
Ich kontrolliere
nun die Lieferscheine,
schaue, ob alles da ist,
was ich bestellt habe
und ob die Qualität stimmt.
Falsch gelieferte Ware
wird zurückgeschickt,
oder wir verhandeln den Preis neu.
Wir benötigen Bulgur,
Gemüse ...
... mehr Salat.
Nach und nach
trifft die Küchenbrigade ein.
Auch für Carlos,
den Saucier in der warmen Küche,
beginnt das Mise en Place
mit einer Kontrolle:
Sind alle Behälter gefüllt?
Zwiebelsauce ...
Ich kontrolliere,
ob für heute noch genügend da ist.
Der Rest ist mehr oder weniger ...
Ich muss den Fisch in den Kühler
stellen. Das ist die Perle.
In einer Küche gibt es
verschiedene Arbeitsschichten.
Die einen beginnen früh
und arbeiten nach der sog.
Zimmerstunde am Nachmittag weiter,
andere kommen später
und arbeiten durch bis zum Schluss.
Gabriel hat heute Frühschicht
und bereitet die Menüs
für die kommende Woche vor.
Nun bereite ich eine süsse Panade
aus Gewürzen, Senf und Honig zu.
Wenn sich das Fleisch
bei 120 °C im Green Egg befindet,
werden das Fett, das Kollagen,
und die Fasern so weich geschmort,
dass man sie auseinanderzupfen kann
und das Fleisch sehr zart ist.
Die Gewürze, die sich
an der Aussenseite befinden,
werden beim Auseinanderzupfen
mit dem saftigen Fleisch
und dem Fett im Innern vermengt.
Aus den Gewürzen und dem Zucker
bildet sich
eine schöne, schwarze Kruste.
Das ist das Beste am Pulled Pork.
So.
Bis nächsten Mittwoch müssen wir
nochmals den Tiefkühler füllen.
Heute werden wir ihn leeren.
Nächste Woche
muss alles frisch aufgefüllt werden.
Das ist die Gemüsebestellung.
Mir fällt ein,
dass wir wieder Kräuter
und Wildspargeln brauchen.
Solche Dinge.
* Flirrende, hohe Klänge *
Von der Gastronomie
sind unzählige Lieferanten abhängig.
Ich besuche Thomas Käser, einen
Gemüsebauern aus dem Kanton Aargau.
Über Zwischenhändler liefert er
rund 60 % seiner Produktion
in die Gastronomie.
Die Preise für seine Produkte
werden von Zwischenhändlern
je nach Angebot und Nachfrage
täglich neu verhandelt.
Bei unseren Produkten
wird es im Schnitt auf jeden Fall
eine Teuerung von 10 % geben.
Bei einigen Produkten
steckt ein erhöhter Treibstoff-
oder Heizenergiebedarf dahinter.
Bei anderen benötigen wir mehr Dün-
ger, der auch teurer geworden ist.
Verpackungen sind
z.T. bis zu 100 % teurer geworden.
Im Schnitt wird die Teuerung
bei etwa 10 % liegen.
Dafür müssen wir eine Lösung finden.
Wir versuchen es täglich,
aber es gelingt uns nicht immer.
Einen Teil
werden wir selbst tragen müssen.
Ab wann lohnt es sich
für dich nicht mehr?
Das kann ich
nicht so genau beziffern.
Es hängt davon ab,
welchen Aufwand wir betreiben.
In den frühen Frühlingsmonaten,
wenn wir den Salat mit Vlies
abdecken und Ernteausfälle haben,
muss der Preis höher sein,
damit die Kosten gedeckt sind,
als im Sommer.
Im Sommer
schlägt das Wasser zu Buche,
aber wir benötigen kein Vlies
und haben keine sonstigen Aufwände.
Wenn wir im Büro
eine Preiskonferenz haben,
müssen wir für denjenigen,
der den Verkauf macht,
die Schmerzgrenze festlegen.
Und wenn du den Betrag
nicht erhältst?
Dann versucht man, vielleicht
noch zwei, drei Tage zu warten,
bis der Kunde vielleicht anbeisst.
Dann wird die Ware vernichtet.
Sie wird untergepflügt und wird
zu Nährstoff für Mikroorganismen.
Wie viel musst du
im Jahr unterpflügen?
Ich denke, übers Ganze gesehen,
liegt es bei 10-15 %.
Es ist 5 Uhr morgens
auf dem Engrosmarkt in Zürich.
Hierhin liefert Thomas Käser sei-
ne Produkte an die Zwischenhändler.
Einer von ihnen ist Bernhard Hug.
Da haben wir die Bestellung
der Ziegelhütte.
Wir sind daran,
sie zu kommissionieren.
Das geschieht im Zeitraum
zwischen 00.30 und 5 Uhr,
in dem wir das machen.
Wir müssen so früh beginnen ...
Der Gastronom
lebt von der Hand in den Mund.
Was er heute bestellt, wird er
im Restaurant auch heute verwerten.
Deshalb müssen wir früh
im Restaurant sein,
damit sie dann
auch genügend Zeit haben,
um das Mise en Place zu machen,
und damit der Service
reibungslos funktioniert,
wenn die Gäste um 12 Uhr
zum Essen kommen.
Die aktuelle Preisentwicklung
für Rohstoffe stellt Produzenten
wie auch Zwischenhändler
vor grosse Herausforderungen.
Es ist problematisch.
Wenn schlussendlich genau der Gast
nicht gewillt ist, mehr zu zahlen,
die Preise oder Kosten
allgemein jedoch steigen,
dann gibt es irgendwo
einen Verlierer.
Das Problem
bei der Gastronomie ist ...
Ein gutes Beispiel
ist 1 kg Nüsslisalat.
Daraus werden nachher ...
... zwölf bis 15 Portionen gemacht.
Und wenn dieser Nüsslisalat
nun 2 Fr. mehr kostet,
dann kostet eine Portion
20 Rp. mehr.
Schlussendlich geht es mehr ...
Eigentlich müsste der Restaurateur
mehr auf die Qualität schauen
anstatt auf diese 20 Rp.
Der Nüsslisalat kostet im Restaurant
nachher zwischen 16 und 18 Fr.
Diese 20 Rp.
machen den Braten nicht fett.
* Pulsierende Musik *
Spielen diese 2 Fr. Aufpreis
auf 1 kg Nüsslisalat
für die Gastronomie
wirklich keine Rolle?
Dazu möchte ich mehr
über die Kostenstruktur
in einem Restaurant erfahren.
Hier ist Bernadette
von der Neuen Blumenau.
Du, habe ich Flanksteaks
bei dir bestellt?
Mach sechs.
Sechs Stück, ja.
Ja.
Sind jeweils zwei Stück drin
oder ist nur eines drin?
(Mann) In der Regel eins.
- Dann leg mir vier dazu, bitte.
Gut, vielen Dank. Bis dann.
Seit 2011 führt Bernadette Lisibach
die Neue Blumenau in Lömmenschwil.
... einem Verein in Kambodscha.
- Ah, ja.
Sie hat sich seither
eine grosse Fangemeinde erkocht
und ist mit 17 Gault-Millau-Punkten
geschmückt.
Das ist super. Zum Wohl miteinander.
- Danke.
Wir haben ein sog. schwei-
zerisch-kambodschanisches Essen.
(Lachend) Ja.
Wir haben hier ein geräuchertes
Tatar vom Hecht aus dem Bodensee,
einen Bulgursalat mit Limettenschaum
im Tartelette
und einen Apfel-Sellerie-Shot,
den wir zum Aperitif servieren.
Aber wie kann Bernadette Lisibach mit
nur 30 Plätzen erfolgreich wirten?
Man macht sich natürlich schon Ge-
danken, was man auf die Karte nimmt,
was man verkaufen will.
Man muss eine Mischrechnung machen,
sodass es nachher stimmt,
auch was die Kosten betrifft.
Und für mich ist auch sehr wichtig:
Es muss das ganze Produkt
gebraucht werden.
D.h., dass wir wirklich
das ganze Produkt verkaufen können.
Silvan,
hast du noch einen roten Chili?
Was ich einkaufe,
muss ich dem Gast verkaufen können,
sonst habe ich schon verloren.
Wenn du eine faire Person bist,
kalkulierst du fair,
und dann muss
dieser Preis bezahlt werden -
sei es in der Gastronomie, der
Baubranche, bei jedem Handwerker.
Wenn das nicht mehr stimmt und man
jeden Preis rechtfertigen muss,
dann ist es eigentlich tragisch.
Den grössten Anteil
machen die Mitarbeiter aus.
Da sprechen wir von etwa 38-45 %.
Ich wusste nicht, wie viel
Blumenkohl ich bestellen sollte,
aber ich kann morgen
noch welchen holen.
Wir haben einen Teil Warenkosten,
die auch Fixkosten sind.
Aber die Fixkosten kann ich hier
eigentlich recht tief halten.
Der Besitzer sieht es so, dass man
die Möglichkeit hat, zu überleben.
Und der Rest ist ...
Ja, der wird so verteilt.
Bei einem Umsatz von 100 Fr.
gehen in der Gastronomie ca. 45 Fr.
in die Löhne der Mitarbeiter,
rund 30 Fr. in die Warenkosten,
weitere 10 Fr. in die Miete,
für Steuern und Unterhalt
nochmals 13 Fr.
Somit bleibt einem Gastronomen -
wenn alles gut läuft -
ein Gewinn von 1-2 Fr.
auf einen Umsatz von 100 Fr.
Zurück in der Ziegelhütte.
Der Mittagsservice beginnt
und die Beiz füllt sich.
Für die Belegschaft steht
ein stressiger Nachmittag bevor,
der keine Fehler erlaubt.
Die kommen wahrscheinlich auch,
das ist Maurus' Apéro.
Den haben wir bereit.
In der Bauernstube wird dekoriert,
sie gehen in die Kegelbahn.
Okay.
Valentina holt die Apérosachen.
Super.
- Genau.
Zum Essen kommen sie um 14 Uhr.
Es gibt nicht viele Reservationen,
aber die Terrasse ist schon voll.
Sehr gut. Wir öffnen noch
den hinteren Teil der Terrasse.
Wenn Maurus gegessen hat,
geht Jeanette nach hinten.
Dann haben wir das Elend
schneller hinter uns.- Genau.
Tagliata vegetarisch,
normale Portion.
Normal.
... Tagliata, auch mit Fleisch.
* Stimmendurcheinander *
Tagliata ohne Fleisch,
also vegetarisch.
Also, Vorspeisen:
Gartensalat.
Dann haben wir Favebohnen.
Und dann haben wir 1 kg ...
Gut, es geht los.
Neu zu schicken sind:
zwei Lebern gross,
zwei Cordon bleu,
ein Züri gross.
Jetzt wird es interessant.
Jetzt kommt die grosse Gruppe.
Dreimal Beilage Spargel,
1 kg Côte de Boeuf,
einmal Kartoffeln.
Einmal Kichererbsen.
Ich kapier es n...
Einmal einen Teller
mit allen drei Beilagen.
Eine Tagliata klein, normal.
Zwei Züri gross.
- Jawohl.
Einmal Brot und Mark.
Einmal deuxième Kutteln.
Die Bons, die unten sind, sind
die Tische, die wir direkt schicken.
Und hier geht es
von rechts nach links.
Die Bons, die oben sind,
sind die zweiten Gänge.
Die werden noch abgerufen.
Sobald da abgerufen wird ...
Wenn "Zweiter Gang abgerufen"
oder was auch immer draufsteht,
nehme ich ihn runter.
Und dann trompete ich das
in die Küche.
Die machen das
und dann wird es geschickt.
Eine Restaurantküche
besteht aus mehreren Posten.
In der Ziegelhütte
ist der Saucier zuständig
für Fleisch, Fisch und Saucen.
Der Entremetier bereitet alle
Beilagen, Vorspeisen und Suppen zu.
Und der Gardemanger
in der kalten Küche
ist zuständig für alle kalten
Vorspeisen, Salate und Desserts.
Am Pass werden die einzelnen
Bestandteile eines Tellers
zusammengesetzt und geschickt.
* Klingel *
Nein, Lebern gross,
zwei Pommes, zwei Tagesgemüse,
ein Côte de Boeuf 700,
ein Schnipo
und zweimal Wurzel vegan.
Wo ist das Vegane?
- Da unten.
Ich brauche jetzt zwei Vegane.
Hä?
* Drollig-schleppende Klänge *
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Wir haben ein grosses Durcheinander
mit diesen Cordon bleus.
(Unwirsch)
Komm, mach ein Cordon bleu! Komm.
* Drollig-schleppende Klänge *
Service, bitte!
Allgemein weiss der Gast
mehr als früher.
Man kocht selbst gern.
Es gibt all diese Kochsendungen
und Workshops.
Die Köche selbst sind auch Popstars.
Einerseits ist es angenehm,
wenn die Leute Bescheid wissen,
andererseits ist es
auch schwieriger,
weil sie z.T. nur meinen,
sie wüssten Bescheid.
Denn ...
Zu Hause gut zu kochen
und in einer Küche
für 150 Personen gut zu kochen,
sind zwei verschiedene Sportarten.
Um den anspruchsvollen Gästen
gerecht zu werden,
müssen sich Gastronomen
klar positionieren.
Die Gäste wollen neben
höchster Qualität der Lebensmittel
auch eine gute Geschichte erleben.
Heute bespricht das Leitungsteam
um Stefan Tamò
und seiner Partnerin Rose Lanfranchi
einen Event im Biergarten,
bei dem ein ganzes Bio-Rind
verarbeitet werden soll.
Der Aufwand, den Gastronomen
für solche Anlässe betreiben müssen,
ist enorm, aber nötig, um die Gäste
anzulocken und zu begeistern.
Wir haben uns überlegt,
daraus einen Solidaritätsanlass,
eine Charity zu machen.
Das ist jetzt zwar
noch nicht sicher,
aber es wäre eine schöne Idee.
Man sagt:
"Es kostet halt, was es kostet."
Das wäre dann
der Name dieses Events.
(Frau) Ah, ja, genau.
* Lachen *
Solidar...
- Solidarnox.
(Beide) Solidarnox.
Es gibt gute Gründe,
es am 4. Juni zu machen.
Wir hätten dann einfach mehr Leute,
die mithelfen könnten,
den Ochsen zu verarbeiten.
Es geht ja auch darum,
wie wir den ganzen Ochsen
an - ich sage jetzt mal -
150 Leute bringen.
Wie machen wir das am besten?
Was funktioniert?
Es geht darum,
heute mal über Ideen nachzudenken.
Das letzte Mal dachten wir über
die verschiedenen Innereien nach.
Es sind ja nicht so viele.
Man fragt sich,
wie das bei 150 Personen
überhaupt funktioniert.
Die Dinge,
von denen wir wenig haben,
könnten wir anfangs vielleicht ...
... apéromässig, flying ...
- ... anbieten.
Dann kriegt halt nicht jeder Herz,
sondern man muss
auf eine gute Mischung achten.
Ja, entweder gefüllt mit Fleisch
oder mit etwas anderem.
Man könnte es auch mit
süss geschmorten Zwiebeln füllen.
Das könnte ich mir auch vorstellen.
Im Garten ein Loch graben
und dort eine Schulter vergraben.
Ah!
Das fände ich total toll.
- Mhm.
Das klingt schon ziemlich lecker.
Ich kann es mir
schon gut vorstellen.
(Michel) Das Menü?
- Ja.
* Muhen, dynamische Klänge *
Eine besonders naturnahe Produktion
betreibt der Biohof Dusch.
Von hier kommt das Rind für den
Solidarnox-Event in der Ziegelhütte.
Mein Name ist Georg Blunier.
Ich bin seit acht Jahren
Landwirt in Graubünden.
Mit meiner Familie,
Lehrlingen und Angestellten
bewirtschafte ich den Hof.
Es ist ein Biohof in den Bergen.
Dieser Betrieb
praktiziert die Hofschlachtung,
um dem Tier einen möglichst
würdevollen Tod zu ermöglichen.
Der grosse Vorteil ist, dass
das Tier, das geschlachtet wird,
in seinem vertrauten Umfeld
bleiben kann.
Es muss nicht
aus der Herde entfernt werden,
sondern kann bleiben, wo es ist.
So können wir den Stress fürs Tier
massiv reduzieren.
Das ist der grösste Vorteil.
So etwas kommt an
bei den Gästen der Ziegelhütte:
Sorgsam produziertes Fleisch
lässt sich gut vermarkten.
Der Küchenchef Michel Grünlinger
und sein Metzger Robi Reiff
wollen die Schlachtung
mit eigenen Augen sehen.
Dazu sind wir zusammen frühmorgens
zu Georg ins Bündnerland gefahren.
Wir sind froh,
wenn ein Tier langsamer wächst.
Dann ist das Futter,
das wir haben, ausreichend.
Wenn die Tiere schnell wachsen,
benötigt man entsprechendes Futter,
damit sie abgedeckt sind.
Daher wird oft Mais eingesetzt.
Verzichtet man darauf,
benötigt man mehr Zeit
und eine Rasse,
die nicht so schnell wächst.
Jedes Tier, das geschlachtet wird,
muss zuerst
gesundheitlich untersucht werden.
Der Tierarzt prüft,
ob das Tier gesund ist
und ob es geschlachtet werden darf.
Das geschieht vor der Schlachtung
oder ganz kurz davor, je nach dem.
Der Metzger muss anwesend sein.
Er ist derjenige, der das Tier
bei uns betäubt und ausbluten lässt.
Ja, Grosse.
Alles gut, komm.
Na, Schona.
Das ist ein besonderer Platz,
zu dem die Tiere immer Zugang haben.
Sie fressen dort
und kennen diesen Platz gut.
Es ist wichtig,
dass sie sich vertraut fühlen.
Dann kriegt das Tier Futter
und frisst dort.
Es ist für Georg Blunier
extrem wichtig,
dass die Tiere nicht gestört werden.
Darum dürfen wir
nur aus der Ferne zuschauen.
Ich finde es ...
... eindrücklich.
So habe ich das noch nie gesehen.
Stopp.
Den meisten Leuten leuchtet es ein,
dass es für das betroffene Tier
eine Verbesserung ist,
wenn es nicht weggebracht wird.
Aber es gibt oft Bedenken,
wie das für die Tiere ist,
die auch anwesend sind.
Man sieht, dass die anderen Tiere
gut daran gewöhnt sind.
In den meisten Fällen
reagieren sie fast gar nicht.
Sie stehen daneben
und fressen weiter.
Das zeigt, dass der eintretende Tod
kein Stressfaktor
für die Tiere darstellt.
Daran sieht man,
wie gut es funktioniert.
Nun habe ich noch
etwas mehr Respekt vor dem Tier.
Ja.
Es ist nicht wirklich schön,
aber ...
... es gehört dazu.
- Ja.
Aber diese Art der Tierhaltung
kann den gesamten Fleischkonsum
in der Schweiz unmöglich abdecken.
Es ist ein ganz kleiner Anteil
der Bevölkerung, der das schätzt
und dem Tier und dem Produkt
Wertschätzung entgegenbringt.
Bei grösseren Massen ist das
in der Schweiz nicht realistisch.
Das Tier merkt von der Schlachtung
selbst nicht viel mehr.
Das einzige Manko ist der
Transport, aber die Wege sind kurz.
Das hier ist perfekt,
aber es ist nicht alltäglich.
* Muhen *
So Fleisch zu produzieren,
ist aufwendig und entsprechend teuer.
Wir vergleichen nicht so sehr
und loten nicht den Marktwert aus,
sondern wir bilden im Preis
primär unsere Produktionskosten ab.
Da wir im Stall
weniger Tiere pro Fläche haben,
ist der Preis natürlich höher.
Dieser Mehraufwand
muss natürlich abgegolten werden
und beeinflusst den Preis.
Meine Achtung für die Tiere hat sich
durch dieses Erlebnis verstärkt.
Gleichzeitig stellt sich mir die
Frage: Ist die Gesellschaft bereit,
für höheres Tierwohl
auch mehr zu bezahlen?
Bei einem Tier
von etwa 500 kg Lebendgewicht
bleiben am Ende
etwa 120-125 kg Fleisch übrig.
Das kostet etwa 5'000 Fr.
1 kg Biofleisch kostet
im Durchschnitt rund 40 Fr.
im Einkauf für den Metzger.
Zusätzlich muss er
noch seine Lagerkosten,
die Verarbeitung
und seine Marge hinzurechnen,
bevor das Filet beim Gastronomen
in der Küche ankommt.
(Robi Reif) Wir liessen die Vorder-
und Hinterviertel lange abhängen.
Nach drei bis vier Wochen
verarbeiteten wir sie.
Wir liessen das Fett
der Vorderviertel aus
und packten die Hinterviertel
damit ein,
damit das Fleisch
nicht zu sehr austrocknet
und schön am Knochen reifen kann.
Das ist die Rindshaxe, die
ich jeweils zuerst herausschneide.
Im Hinterviertel des Tiers sitzen
die edlen Fleischstücke eines Rinds.
Dieses ganze Stück.
Wir beginnen mit dem Entrecote.
Das ist dieses Stück hier.
Danach ist das Filet dran.
Hier ist das Côte de Boeuf,
das Rindskotelett.
Dies ist die Rindshaxe,
dies das Eckstück,
hier der Huftdeckel,
der Runde Mocken,
das Fischli und das Rosenstück.
Hier sind die Nuss,
das Pastorenstück,
die Unterspälte und die Huft.
Das sind alle Stücke.
In der Gastronomie sind
die Warenkosten für Lebensmittel
neben den Lohnkosten
der wichtigste Faktor.
Schaut man sich
die Preise im Restaurant an,
könnte man denken, dass man
mit Wirten viel Geld verdient.
Okay, wer hat dir das erzählt?
Ich treffe mich mit Erik Hämmerli,
einem Urgestein
der Zürcher Gastronomie.
Er ist seit 1984 in dieser Branche
und führt seit 15 Jahren
das Restaurant Bederhof.
So, Ladys, el Schnitzel.
Bon Appétit. Geniesst es.
Laut einer Statistik sind 63 % der
Betriebe in der Schweiz defizitär.
Ich glaube, das stimmt nicht,
aber man kann
nirgends lustvoller Geld verlieren
als in der Gastronomie.
Eine Küche
kostet rasch 200'000-300'000 Fr.
Das Teure daran ist das,
was du hörst:
die Lüftung,
die übers Dach rausgeht.
Wenn es nicht bereits eine Lüftung
gibt, reichen 1 Mio. Fr. nicht.
Wie berechnet ein Gastronom
den Preis eines Menüs?
Da wären zuerst mal die Warenkosten.
Für das 200 g schwere Rindsfilet
18 Fr., für Kräuterbutter 70 Rp,
die Sauce 1 Fr.,
Gewürze 10 Rp., Gemüse 60 Rp.
und die Beilage, Pommes frites,
80 Rp.
Dann sind wir bei 20-22 Fr.
Dann müsste man
Faktor 4,5 hinzufügen.
Damit der Koch,
der Strom, die Miete,
der Unterhalt, der kaputte Ofen,
der repariert werden muss,
derjenige, der den Teller serviert,
und derjenige, der den Teller
abwäscht, bezahlt werden.
Dann sind wir bei 80-83 Fr.
Das bezahlt ein Schweizer nicht.
Daher reduzieren wir
die Preise so stark,
wie es unsere Schmerzgrenze zulässt.
Wir müssen uns die ganze Zeit ...
durchmogeln.
Wenn wir es
richtig berechnen würden,
müsste Zürich
noch viel teurer werden.
Weisst du, welche der Gastronomen
am meisten Geld verdienen?
Die Sushi-Köche.
Denn jeder ist bereit,
für zwei Stückchen Fisch
18 Fr. zu bezahlen.
Dort ist
eine richtige Marge enthalten.
Aber sobald ein Cordon bleu oder
ein Wiener Schnitzel 45 Fr. kosten,
gibt es ein riesiges Geschrei.
Das subventioniert man
quer durch ...
... die Leber mit Rösti,
die Pommes frites
und die Kuchen, die man verkauft.
Ich sage es mal so.
Der Gastrokritiker Real Picky Gourmet
akzeptiert Preiserhöhungen
nur unter gewissen Bedingungen.
Er will anonym bleiben, damit er
in Restaurants nicht erkannt wird
und nicht besser
als andere Gäste behandelt wird.
Ich könnte
mit einer Preiserhöhung leben,
aber dann will ich höchste Qualität.
Dann gibt es keine Fertigprodukte
in der Küche mehr
und alle Bouillons, Saucen und Jus
werden selbst hergestellt.
Es müsste qualitativ absolut
hochwertige Ware gekauft werden.
Dann könnte ich
mit einer Preiserhöhung leben.
Ich will Handwerk,
Kulinarik und absolute Top-Qualität.
Das darf auch etwas kosten.
Wir verlieren unsere Kultur,
weil wir weder bereit sind,
etwas zu leisten noch zu bezahlen.
Ich frage mich,
wo das Geld hinfliesst.
Ein T-Shirt ist wichtiger
als eine gute Suppe.
In den rund 23'000 Gastronomie-
betrieben in der Schweiz
verpflegen sich täglich
rund 2,9 Mio. Menschen.
Die Anzahl der Beschäftigten
betrug im Jahr 2021 rund 225'000.
Das Gastgewerbe ist durch eine
besonders hohe Arbeitsintensität
gekennzeichnet.
Eine Wertschöpfung von 1 Mio. Fr.
muss durch 16 Beschäftigte
erwirtschaftet werden,
während es
im Durchschnitt der Gesamtwirtschaft
nur gut sechs Beschäftigte sind,
die 1 Mio. erwirtschaften.
Die zwei ganz entscheidenden
Merkmale am Anfang sind für mich,
ob ich rasch begrüsst werde
und rasch eine Karte erhalte.
Der Rest ist nicht so schwierig.
Es gehört natürlich dazu,
dass das Personal
höflich und zuvorkommend ist.
Man sollte jedoch auch
qualifizierte Antworten erhalten.
Wenn ich eine Frage zu einer Zutat
oder zur Zubereitung habe,
erwarte ich vom Servicepersonal
eine kompetente Antwort -
und zwar aus dem Stegreif.
Wie angekündigt verwenden wir
ab heute die neue Speisekarte.
Sie heisst "Hello Spring".
Diesen Namen trug sie schon
in den letzten Jahren.
Sie gilt ab heute
bis etwa Ende Juni.
Ein Hinweis v.a. für diejenigen,
die neu sind:
Die Speisekarte
bleibt in den nächsten drei Monaten
nicht genau gleich.
Wir fangen mal so an,
und in diesen drei Monaten werden
immer wieder Dinge ausgetauscht.
Es ist an euch, euch
über die Änderungen zu informieren.
Die Anforderungen an das Personal
sind in den letzten Jahren
kontinuierlich gestiegen.
Kellner/-innen müssen Auskunft geben
können über Herkunft der Speisen,
Zubereitungsart,
passende Weinbegleitung.
Und das, wenn immer möglich,
in verschiedenen Sprachen.
Dazu braucht es
gut ausgebildetes Personal.
Im Anschluss an die Sitzung kann sich
das Servicepersonal in der Küche
ein Bild machen, wie die neuen Teller
ausschauen, wie sie zubereitet sind,
welche Variationen möglich sind.
Anschliessend werden sie
vom Personal degustiert.
(Frau) Was für eine Sauce ist das?
- Ponzu.- Lecker.
Nicht erst seit der Pandemie
gefährdet ein dramatischer Mangel
an Fachkräften die Branche.
Aber die Pandemie
hat die Situation verschärft.
In dieser Zeit
ist die Zahl der Beschäftigten
um beinahe 40'000 Personen gesunken.
Durch die Kurzarbeit sank der Lohn
um 20 %, das Trinkgeld sank um 100 %.
Diese empfindlichen Lohneinbussen
und die Unsicherheit der Branche
veranlasste viele Fachkräfte, eine
sicherere Beschäftigung zu suchen.
Auch Berichte von
unterbesetzten Restaurants und Küchen
tragen dazu bei, dass überforderte
und gestresste Mitarbeiter
die Gastronomie verlassen.
Ich glaube, die Leute arbeiten
teils nicht gern im Gastgewerbe,
weil wir scheisse behandelt werden.
Selbst ich als gestandener Mann
werde behandelt wie ein Schuljunge.
"Du, Coboy, bring mir mal ein Bier."
Erstens bin ich kein Coboy,
sondern ein Cowboy, und es heisst:
"Dürfte ich
bitte eine Stange haben?"
Dann ist es okay.
Der Gast hat das Gefühl,
er sei König,
ohne zu wissen,
wie sich ein König aufführt.
Wie sagt man jemandem, dass es cool
ist, am Wochenende zu arbeiten?
Ich kann das Restaurant
am Sonntag nicht schliessen.
Das würde ich nicht lange überleben.
Dann würde man mich köpfen.
D.h., ich brauche Mitarbeitende,
die am Sonntag gern arbeiten.
Das findet niemand sehr attraktiv.
Abends zu arbeiten
ist auch nicht attraktiv.
Du arbeitest in der Freizeitbranche.
D.h., du arbeitest per se dann,
wenn alle anderen frei haben.
Willst du das?
René Kaufmann führte zusammen
mit seiner Frau bis im Sommer 2022
das Gasthaus Rössli in Illnau.
Einmal Zander klein ist hinten,
oder?- Ja.
Bitte rein. Und die Trilogie
mit Reis, okay?- Jawohl.
Rene Kaufmann
war Lehrmeister des Jahres 2016.
Die Förderung des Nachwuchses
ist für Rene Kaufmann
eine Herzensangelegenheit.
Nachwuchs in der Gastronomie
zu finden, ist schwierig geworden.
Durch die Pandemie
haben wir etwas an Glaubwürdigkeit
und an Wert verloren,
da es sich um ein Gewerbe handelt,
das einfach
geschlossen werden konnte.
Nun ist es unsere Aufgabe,
dafür zu sorgen,
dass die Leute wieder zurückkommen.
Neu Tisch 9: Sans Premier,
zwei Amuse-Gueules.
Drei Amuse-Gueules für Tisch 10,
bitte.
Zwei Gemischte - Haus und italienne,
ein Nüssli/Speck italienne.
Deuxième Kalbsleber, Rösti,
Zander, Reislingsauce, Reis,
Rindsfilet 120 g, Béarnaise, Nudeln.
Nicki, eine Béarnaise, bitte.
Rühr ein bisschen,
schneller, schneller.
Aber um neuen Nachwuchs zu finden,
muss die Gastronomie
Massnahmen ergreifen.
Abschmecken, fertig, erledigt.
Das Nachwuchsmarketing
ist im Dachverband angesiedelt,
bei GastroSuisse.
Dort gibt es berufehotelgastro.ch.
Im Sommer
werden gezielt Schulen angeschrieben
und man stellt das Angebot vor.
Bei der Aktion rockyourfuture
bieten die Betriebe den Jugendlichen
während zwei Wochen -
einmal im Frühling
und einmal im Herbst -
einen Einblick in die Branche
und zeigen ihnen, was sie machen.
An der Allgemeinen Berufsschule
in Zürich
werden die angehenden Köch/-innen
zusätzlich zum Lehrbetrieb
ausgebildet.
Roland Menzi unterrichtet
seit 23 Jahren an der ABZ
und ist Initiant der Talentklasse.
Um halb müssen wir sie schicken.
Richtet die zweite Charge an.
In die Talentklasse
werden nach einem Jahr
die Lernenden aufgenommen,
die mehr Interesse haben,
die im Beruf mehr erreichen wollen,
die die Herausforderung suchen,
die das Tüpfelchen auf dem i suchen
und mit Engagement
eine Stufe weitergehen wollen.
Für FOOD ZURICH
produzierten wir Pinchos.
Wir stehen mit den Küchenchefs
der sieben grossen Zürcher Hotels
im Austausch.
Die Lernenden präsentieren ihnen
erstmals die Pinchos.
So sehen wir,
was wir noch verbessern müssen
und wir haben bis zum Start
von FOOD ZURICH genügend Zeit,
um nochmals zu trainieren.
Für Roland Menzi ist die
Attraktivitätssteigerung der Branche
ein grosses Thema.
Die jungen Leute haben immer noch
Interesse an der Gastronomie.
Heute haben sie
teils geregelte Arbeitszeiten.
Nur wenige haben noch
eine klassische Zimmerstunde.
Sie arbeiten
nicht mehr zwingend postenweise -
unterteilt in Gardemanger,
Saucier und Entremetier -,
sondern es gibt heute
ganz verschiedene Modelle.
Viele Restaurants haben
sonntags und montags geschlossen.
Früher hatte man nur unter der Woche
und nie am Wochenende frei.
Das hat sich heute geändert.
Die Branche selber fordert
höhere Löhne, eine Viertagewoche
und die Abschaffung von Schichtarbeit
und Zimmerstunde.
Die Viertagewoche ist ein Thema.
Bei uns ist sie jedoch
unmöglich umzusetzen.
Wenn wir sechs Tage lang den
ganzen Tag geöffnet haben wollen,
bräuchten wir noch mehr Personal.
Wieso will man nicht
im Schichtdienst arbeiten?
Will man den ganzen Nachmittag lang
im Büro sitzen?
Wir gehen im Sommer
jeden Nachmittag ins Schwimmbad.
Das ist doch toll.
Ich begreife es nicht.
Rauf mit den Löhnen,
aber das läuft letztlich
auf ein Minusgeschäft hinaus,
wenn man die höheren Kosten
nicht auf die Preise abwälzen kann.
Man bräuchte eigentlich
auch Solidarität seitens der Gäste,
um die Attraktivität
der Gastrobranche zu steigern.
Es ist etwas Schönes,
einen Gast bedienen
und glücklich machen zu dürfen.
Das alleine ist schon sehr viel Lob.
Letztlich
geht es nicht immer ums Geld.
Heute Mittag
hatte ich einen tollen Gast,
der mir extrem viel Wertschätzung
entgegenbrachte.
Ich glaube, wir müssen
die jungen Leute damit abholen.
Das, was fehlt,
ist die Freude, die Euphorie,
jemandem etwas Gutes zu tun.
Darauf sollte man stolz sein.
Der Gast und der Beizer
sind wie die Eiche und der Trüffel.
Wer was ist, ist mir egal, aber der
eine kann nicht ohne den anderen.
Es ist eine absolute Symbiose.
Gastfreundschaft heisst ja,
dass der Gast mein Freund ist.
Eigentlich möchte ich ja,
dass jeder, der zu mir kommt,
freundlich und herzlich bedient wird
und sich wohlfühlt.
* Langsame Bassklänge *
In der Ziegelhütte kann der Anlass
mit dem Rind vom Biohof Dusch
nicht wie ursprünglich geplant
durchgeführt werden.
Ursprünglich
sollte es ein Solidaritätsfest
rund um den Ochsen werden.
Wir hätten es Solidarnox genannt.
Davon sahen wir jedoch ab,
da wir zu wenig Personal
und zu viel Druck haben.
Nun servieren wir
den Ochsen am Weinfest.
Die Vorbereitungen für das Weinfest
laufen schon seit dem frühen Morgen.
Wegen des akuten Personalmangels
bin auch ich für heute im Team
und helfe am Weinfest mit.
Um 13 Uhr kommen die ersten Gäste.
Die Küche ist offiziell
ab 14 Uhr geöffnet.
Wenn jemand bereits um 13 Uhr sagt,
er sei am Verhungern,
lassen wir ihn nicht verhungern.
Gut.
Rösch und Bruno in der Hütte.
- Ja.
Tschikki, Manu,
Nils und Leo am Grill.
Miriam am Salatbüffet.
Wie viele haben schon reserviert?
- 120.
Wir verkaufen heute alles. Gut.
Danke.
- Also, auf, auf.
Meine Ausbildung zum Koch
hat mich gelehrt, was es heisst,
in der Profiküche zu stehen.
Meine Leidenschaft fürs Kochen
ist nach wie vor vorhanden,
aber die Hitze,
der Stress und der Druck
waren mir
nach meiner Ausbildung zu viel,
um diesen Job täglich zu machen.
Das nehmen wir nachher weg.
- Dann haben wir Platz.
Hey!
* Jubel *
Ich glaube, dass die
Gesetzmässigkeiten der Gastronomie
wie Arbeits- und Öffnungszeiten
bestehen bleiben.
Denn die Gäste wollen, wie auch ich,
weiterhin am Abend
und übers Wochenende ihre Freizeit
bei einem guten Essen
und einem Glas Wein geniessen.
Diese Gewohnheiten
werden sich nicht ändern.
Und zum Glück für uns alle
hat die Branche immer noch
viele gute Mitarbeiter/-innen,
die den Umständen zum Trotz
von sich sagen:
"Für die Gastronomie
wirst du geboren."
5-6 Min.
Ich bringe es dir nach hinten.
(Bernadette Lisibach)
Es ist wichtig,
dass sich ein Gastronom
in den Gast hineinversetzt.
Man muss den Gast dort abholen kön-
nen, wo er ist, und flexibel sein.
Man muss ihm die Sicherheit geben,
dass man für ihn da ist
und dass er an diesem Abend
schöne 3-4 Std. verbringen kann.
* Sie spielen "Free Fallin'"
von Tom Petty. *
Zuerst kommt die Freude an dem,
was man tut, und dann das Geld.
Das Geld kommt immer zuletzt.
Mit Geld startet man,
aber wenn man das Geld in den Mit-
telpunkt stellt, hat man verloren.
(Erik Hämmerli) Essen ist Kultur.
Das ist unsere kulturelle Identität.
Ohne den Gast bin ich nichts.
Ich bin wie ein Schauspieler
ohne Bühne oder ohne Leinwand.
Wenn ich in der Küche
etwas produziere,
das nicht gegessen wird,
bin ich tot.
Dann ist meine Lebensgrundlage weg.
Der Gast ist ganz wichtig.
Für die Gastronomie,
wie wir sie leben,
benötigt man ganz viel
Identifikation mit dem Betrieb,
mit dem Beruf und den Menschen.
Es ist ein Beruf
am und für den Menschen.
Es ist ein anstrengender Beruf.
Man benötigt
wirklich Durchhaltevermögen.
Aber es ist der schönste Beruf,
den es gibt.
# Free fallin'.
# And I'm free.
# I'm free fallin'.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
A. Werlen / M. Waldner - 2022